hey I was going everybody welcome back
to the next episode in this labs CPP
labs for school episode where we're just
going through all the labs this is found
yeah at this website look at the lab
assignments or at the end of set to
apologize for the delay just got a
little sidetracked with other things but
I do intend on still going through all
of these ok so we left off from last
episode let's see we had finished 6 I
believe yeah looks like we finished 6
here and we're just gonna I'm just gonna
walk through them all from here so that
was 6 and I am using Windows to do this
this is a cygwin so this is essentially
like a Linux environment so if you're
using Linux it's great views and windows
to follow along you should be able to do
so in Visual Studio Community Edition
warrant with cygwin in Visual Studio
code should essentially be the same
so the next set of questions in this lab
is basically what is the output of the
program so they just want a simple
answer and so you're supposed to walk
through it and and find out so let's
walk through these so integer x equals
10 and another integer Y is also being
instantiated and then the next line sets
y equal to X plus plus so this is a post
increment so why would he become equal
to 10 and then X after this is now 11 so
Y is 10 and there we go and if we could
run the code and I'm sure we'd get the
same thing let's see let's look at the
next one this is exactly the same except
they're outputting the why are the X
sorry first of those backwards so same
thing stanching the nexus 10 and a Y and
setting y equal to X plus plus so Y
becomes 10x increments host or after and
then X will be 11 here now the thing
about this
well I'll talk about it more a second
there's something a little tricky about
these and also vague okay so it's uh x
equals 10x plus plus
now what's X X is of course 11 and if we
do this again into x equals 10 and y and
then we set y equal to the pre increment
of X so X will increment here to 11 and
then it will set to y so I should also
be 11 yeah very good it's like we're
seeing that according to the answer so
we're following it correctly and now int
x equals 10 and AC out of an increment
of the X so this should be 11 as well
since it's pre yes it is 11 and this
should be 10 over here because it's post
so while it does end up increasing to 11
during this particular line it's still
going to be a 10 and now we get to
number 8 this is a little trickier and
also I have been I've done a little
research on this subject and it looks
like there's no guaranteed order of
operations on these so these might be
different in different compilers just
FYI but apparently they're looking for a
certain answer here in this lab but yes
since there's no guarantee of orders I
don't I think there isn't C++ standard
Oh 17 17 and beyond there is a
guaranteed order of operations but
anything older there isn't so that's
what I found I don't remember the source
I think I read it on some technical
thing to receive plus plus and it seemed
accurate so that's not just a yeah
that's where it comes from
so we said n X equal to 10 and and then
we have a Y and then we set y equal to X
plus X plus plus so this is gonna be 10
and this is also going to be 10 and then
X is going to increment afterwards so we
shouldn't get a a y of 20 because it
should just be 10
ten let's see if that's the case no it
shows 21 so something a little different
is going on here I think they're well
like I said it might be different on
different compilers but if someone knows
and the exact answer you're welcome to
tag this area of the video and leave a
comment but I think what happens here is
it does this one and while this
evaluates to ten it post increments and
then when it evaluates this one it's 11
so it ends up being 10 plus 11 I'm
guessing that's what's going on here and
then it's gonna be a similar thing here
on the second part of it
same initialization then y equals plus
plus X X plus plus and X so on based on
the findings of last one I would assume
this would be 10 plus another 10 but now
it has incremented to 11 and then plus
12 so 10 plus 10 plus 12 because it's
the post incremented to 11 and then if
pre incremented to 12 so I would think
why would be 32 here let's see if that's
what they get know they get 35 so that's
entirely different than what I
calculated and if someone knows the
exact reasoning for it because it
doesn't seem like it adds up to me
either and yeah when I studied up the
subject like I said I basically found
that there's no guaranteed order you
could get different results don't do
this this is kind of bad not even just
style just bad consistency type
programming so that that's what I found
take that that's what you will and looks
like we have one more and it's a very
similar thing except it has these in a
different order so it assumes I'm
assuming question 8 is specifying that
the order of these matters very
distinctly and supposable he doesn't C++
17 I'd have to do my own testing but if
we just take this for example and put it
into our compiler we'll see what we get
it is this one right here and we will go
ahead and run this oopsie okay so CD
bars so I could bring
so ever so you guys could see it I'm
just going into the folder where this
file is and I'm gonna run that make file
and we also get 35 in our compiler so
that's interesting so I am apparently
walking through this wrong I'm not sure
how exactly yeah
I'm really not not sure why exactly
because in this one it seems to assume
we go from right to left but in this one
it doesn't so I it's a little more all
over the place it seems like let's let's
do one more assumption real quick let's
say this is 11 let's say this is an 11
this is a 12 that would equal 34 so I'll
say this is an 11 this is a 12 in this
is a 12 and now would equal 35 is that
what it's evaluating to 11 plus 12 in
the plus 10 or another 12 plus 11 plus
12 plus 12 is it that would add up to 35
but that doesn't make sense to me
because okay this one's a pre-increment
yeah that makes sense this one's a post
it should still be 11 right I don't know
I don't understand the order there but
apparently I get the same thing here so
sorry for not knowing the exact answer
but hopefully we can shed some light on
that based on further discussion later
int x equals 10 I'm just doing the last
one here and x equals 10 and then it's
another situation and let's just see
what this one equals I would think it
would equal I don't know let's say 10
plus 11 plus 12 so 33 yeah I think that
one does turn to 33 so maybe no matter
where well maybe it really matters where
this pre-increment one is still seems a
little weird to me that they plug this
one I don't see what it turns into now
okay I'm gonna grab this if I can keeps
wanting to grab the frame with a website
let's stand in there and let's see if we
get thirty three yeah we do
very good okay so I'm just gonna cat my
make file here so you guys could see
what it is it's very simple this assault
hasn't it so it builds the program and
runs it you should already know that if
you saw any of the previous episodes
what is the output of the following
program okay so this is eight set with
which uses i/o manip so through this old
code and we'll say we're on to number
nine so set with basically sets the
width of your console output so you can
line things up and make specific graphs
with you know numbers right down the
line and things like that so it just
helps you with formatting and we let's
see what we get here because it's gonna
push them all to the right I'm just
gonna run make and yeah it pushes the
starting digit at least to the width of
five so it like sets the width of the
column to five so you can see this 77 is
got three spaces in front of it is
hundreds so it starts the end of the
number and fills to the left apparently
hates how that works so you could set
five if you wanted a header to be right
there like something like let's just
call it some variable called old gas
just a random thing
and oh there's there's no run target on
my make file so now you can see it kind
of looks like I'm a cold I'm just a
that's usually what they're used for but
it could be for other things too yeah
this works just as well for outputting
to files what is the output of the
following program load net equals this
number we say precision 2 so this change
is something about how see how it works
it sets the precision to this sets the
fixed point I believe said F on the co2
we're setting it to fixed and show point
so the show point will show this decimal
no matter what fixed I don't know what
iOS fixed does let's have a look so I
can come I can just search it on google
here and you can always do the same if
you're ever stuck on something and we'll
find out in exactly what it does sets
the float field format flag for the
string to fixed when the flow field is
set to fixed floating point values are
written using fixed point notation the
value is represented with exactly as
many digits in the decimal part
specified by the precision field okay so
since we set the precision of 2 is just
gonna say it's fixed to 2 and I think
show point just always shows the point
even if there's nothing to show I could
be wrong correct me if I'm wrong on that
comments below and as you can see it
just fixes at those two digits so that's
a way to sort of represent money with
like a float or double but another pro
tip do not represent money with floats
and doubles doesn't work because money
only goes to two digits for the cents
and this is calculating beyond two
digits so you could get some oddities
and end up with extra or missing money
so basically what you do is use integers
only instead and just count the number
of them
like 100 would be a dollar and zero
cents and you just don't use decimals if
you're actually working with money so
just FYI hope that makes sense if not
ask for clarification below is that it
did we finish this we did okay so we
finished sat - we'll start with set
three and the next episode thank you for
tuning in I hope you learned a few
things or at least got a refresher and I
know you're all enjoying the new year
may the weather be good for you in your
life 2020 let's do this and if you're
watching this and in the future welcome
to the Past peace out guys see you in
the next step